ton visage vraiment de reformuler le
groupe faudrait beaucoup s'exercer pour
que ça fonctionne maintenant alors
arrête de faire comme si ça te manquait
pas je parle des femmes et hurlements
les pourboires les pourboires te manque
c'est vrai et toi tu veux faire comment
avec ta jambe c'est fini la danse pour
moi mais j'ai un nouvel atout je ne suis
pas un clown merde magicien tu
ssure déménage je suis fatigué de faire
entrer mais ça manque cachette le
dernier que j'ai reçu était tellement
bruyant que quand je l'ai laissé entrer
par derrière j'ai vraiment cru que c'est
cri allait être réveillé mais on n'a pas
de porte de derrière
tiens tu auras besoin de ça merci mais
c'est un aller simple je signe il n'y a
qu'une seule manière de réussir à ta
manière
tu te rends compte qu'à une époque on
avait la meilleure troupe de danseurs
toute la ville les chocs les chips
ensemble étaient plein les poches Mister
face Mr body Mister slim sexy docteur
hips et bien sûr illimitable Mister Big
[Applaudissements]
prends-moi ton public de soi ne sera pas
facile
attends tu veux que je devienne
stripteaseur mais je sais pas danser je
suis un magicien
[Musique]
dis-moi que tu vois ce que je vois on va
relancer la machine
pas parler depuis des années comment tu
vas les trouver mais en fait vous êtes
complètement barge pardonnez-moi mais
c'est certainement l'idée la plus
stupide et quadruplés frère
en s'amusait bien à l'époque oui ça
c'est bien vrai merci d'accueillir le
docteur xanderpès
plate il faut que tu remontes sur scène
et fais-le à ta manière
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu fais pas faire le pas
sur la gauche s'il va vers la droite je
peux pas bouger vite comme ça horrible
alors sans plus attendre mesdames les
[Musique]
chocs
boom boom boom boom tu vas trop haut tu
boum boum bien trop ouais il a trop beau
[Musique]